ah
look who hasn't had gay thoughts who
tux
do you take flipper to be your lawfully
wedded wife
i do i do
by the power vested in me from the
department of parks and recreation i now
pronounce you husband and wife
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
okay well at least you're married
i'll say making babies
well not those two those are both boy
penguins
i'm sorry
tux and flipper are both boys
so you should have pronounced them
husband and husband technically that's
awesome
still you couldn't have asked for better
weather
[Applause]
this place is outstanding
great call leslie knope
look even ben's dancing
hey leslie some guy who owns a gay bar
sent you a cake pawnee has a gay bar
yeah
the bulge
it's behind my house
the bulge is a gay bar
ah the knights i've wasted there on the
house leslie oh thank you
i'm sort of a gay hero
you know why tonight's fun because
everyone's so gay
and they know how to have fun and the
dancing
just
it's everyone is just who they are and
who they are is just stone cold gay it's
lazy oh that's the no you're my hero
leslie you are looking hot
thank you ben
i'm really enjoying this hug
so nice but i need to tell you something
this one is on us well if it's free
leslie no
[Applause]
she's
[Applause]
gentlemen first of all
i would just like to say thank you so
much for throwing me this party
especially on a night when the colts are
playing
ah this is green
[Applause]
[Laughter]
when i
married those penguins
you're chanting my name
[Applause]
i just have one thing to say together we
can change
[Applause]
[Music]
hey there
how's it going great
thanks
can i buy you a drink
oh i'm very flattered but this is my
stunningly gorgeous date ann perkins
oh
hi hi
sorry oh no problem in fact let me buy
all of you a drink for being so
welcoming today leslie hey hey
this is my boyfriend derek this is
derek's boyfriend ben
hey
oh
wait sorry what's the situation
what do you mean how does this work
derek is gay but he's straight for me
but he's gay for ben and ben's really
gay for derek and i hate ben
it's not that complicated
i'm having such a nice time tonight i've
met many interesting people and there's
two bisexual guys here and i got both of
their phone numbers
hey guys
hey
remember my boyfriend derek
and his boyfriend ben yeah hi
it's totally okay that you didn't wear a
costume
i did i'm a straight person
hey
sorry i'm late see
nice screwing buddy the gentleman over
by the bar there sent you over this
glass of wine and his business card
okay
okay
fine we are gathered here today to join
craig middlebrooks
and typhoon montelban
in holy matrimony i don't know about
this i'm very scared oh just relax you
nervous nelly you're right we love each
other
and the tax break is substantial will
the best man please present the rings
good luck you too
typhoon my love
happy anniversary
do you have any regrets not one
not a single one do you have any regrets
are you kidding thousands most recently
this trout sorry it's a little bit lame
right now but we'll get it going i
passed up a gay halloween party to be
here do you know how much fun gay
halloween parties are
last year i saw three jonas brothers
make out with three robert pattisons
it was
can't believe this is amazing gay bar
yeah especially with that heterosexual
cowboy greeting us on the way in our fun
last night i had three drinks named
after me so that's pretty fun
plus ben and derek are taking me
shopping on saturday and we are gonna
find out my actual bra
size i guess i'm kind of like queen of
the gays
fully for you
you